in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I take a look at saving some costs
by using a different network tier will
our performance stack up stay tuned to
find out if you take a hard look at your
applications network data you'll find
that it's not consistent in terms of
priority I mean it's really nice that
your app can use a two terabyte
connection for video but do you really
need that much performance when
uploading your log content or better yet
does it make sense to pay for that
performance when uploading your log
content this is where Google clouds new
standard tier networking comes in it
offers lower throughput higher latency
and lower cost than the default premium
tier the difference between the two
tiers has to do with how long packets
stay on the public Internet now see in
the premium tier packets enter Google's
networks as close to the user as
possible and then travel on Google's
backbones before getting to the VM the
standard tier on the other hand allows
packets to enter Google's networks as
close to the VM as possible spending
more time traveling on the public
Internet and since it's spending less
time on Google's network it costs less
as a result now as a developer there's
two big questions how much performance
am I losing and how much money am I
savings to figure out the first question
let's take a look at the worst case
scenario transferring data across an
ocean I set up two VMs in u.s. central
one and configured one of them for the
premium tier and the other for the
standard tier then from a non GCP
machine in the UK fetched a 100k image
from each instance about 500 times the
graph here shows the premium tier is
about 41% faster on average than the
standard tier now we can also run this
test in the best-case scenario where the
client and the server are geographically
closer to each other in this
configuration we can see that the
standard tier is only about 8 percent
slower than the premium tier now at the
time of this video GCPs tiered Network
is still an alpha so lots of stuff is
still in flux as such keep an eye on the
official site for more information and
if you want to know more about our tests
or how you could use the standards here
to save your apps and money check out
the article linked in the description
below and don't forget to check out the
rest of our cloud performance Atlas
content because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts
you